es sind die größten phänomene im
universum aber wir wissen einfach gar
nicht über sie oder so gut wie gar nicht
dunkle materie und dunkle energie
zusammen machen wir nach berechnungen
rund 96 prozent des universums aus aber
wir haben noch nicht die geringste spur
entdeckt obwohl nicht die geringste ist
nicht ganz korrekt immer mal wieder gibt
es
ich sage mal hinweise aber bisher ist
nur ein sicher dass michael jetzt wurde
ein hinweis auf die dunkle materie
entdeckt und lag direkt vor unserer nase
in der sonne
wie bitte vor unseren augen dunkle
materie jetzt einen klick vom feinsten
herzlich willkommen
es ist wirklich zu merken dunkle materie
und dunkle energie wind einfach nicht
aufzuspüren dabei machen sie einen
großteil des universums aus nur vier
prozent des weltalls sind materie 73%
dunkle energie und 23 prozent sind
dunkle materie und diese dunkle materie
können wir auch überall beobachten
karaki name drehen sie schneller um das
zentrum ihrer galaxien als sie sich mit
der existierenden materie drehen würden
nur dunkle materie kann das erklären in
der stärke von gravitationslinsen also
quasi durch gravitation die raumzeit
fernen objekten aktive linsen wirken
auch hier ist die stärke der linken nur
mit der gravitation der dunklen materie
zu erklären aber das ist sie ich habe er
letztlich hier von der theorie berichten
dass sie aus schwarzen löchern bestehen
könnte allerdings würden sie auch in der
teilchenphysik gesucht und zb in winz
vermutet weekly interacting messe
statisches auf deutsch schwach wechsel
wirkende massereiche teilchen oder in
aktionen wie würden in sternen entstehen
aber während kaum auf spürbar weil sie
nicht mit materie wechselwirken aber bei
der wechselwirkung mit starken
magnetfeldern würden sie in photonen im
frequenzbereich der röntgenstrahlung
umgewandelt das heißt hier auf der erde
müssten sie eigentlich gemessen werden
können wurden wir aber bisher nicht
bisher denn jetzt haben android und
seine kolleginnen und kollegen von der
university of leicester in
großbritannien wie vielleicht gefunden
veränderungen der röntgenstrahlung auf
der der sonne zugewandten seite der erde
dies ohne aktion eigentlich nicht geben
dürfte
wie stellt nämlich in den messdaten des
esa weltraum röntgenteleskop xmm newton
der letzten 5 jahre fest dass die
röntgenstrahlung auf der der sonne
zugewandten seite der erde immer leicht
erhöht war
in ihrer studie untersuchten sie jetzt
alle möglichen ursachen für eine solche
erhöhung der röntgen spannung und
konnten sie aber stück für stück
ausschließen was noch lied als ursache
waren die aktionen
das ist ein faszinierendes ergebnis
meint martin busker denn der ofc mit
zurzeit die aber nicht alle
astrophysiker wird so begeistert ist
können auch andere bisher unbekannte
phänomene geben
die ursache für diese messergebnisse
seien meinen sie
es ist und bleibt also spannend wenn es
um die dunkle materie geht wenn es
wieder neues dazu gibt dann erst
das natürlich hier nichts dazu verpassen
dann drücken wir hier ein abo auf und
vergesse nicht den auch die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit dunkle materie rätsel
gelöst spielen schwarzer löcher eine
rolle
und noch mehr zum thema dunkle materie
wenn es euch interessiert einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran